all of these different hoaxes that they
did I mean you know a lot of people
would say that's probably quite normal I
want to give Trump some credit now
because he does deserve credit for
certain things and I did vote for him
last time and I might vote for him next
time because politics really blows um
here is Trump last night on his town
hall saying that he has no time for
Retribution if anything his retribution
will be doing the right thing for the
country well first of all a lot of
people would say that that's not so bad
look what they did Russia Russia Russia
hoax the FBI Twitter hoax the 51
intelligence agents hoax all of these
different hoaxes that they did I mean
you know a lot of people would say
that's probably quite normal I'm not
going to have time for Retribution we're
going to make this country so successful
again I'm not going to have time for
Retribution and and remember this our
ultimate retribution is Success our
that's a good line that's a good line
and that actually is the truth right the
retribution is not arresting the
journalists and the gays as Whoopi is
trying to scare everyone to think the
retribution is oh you guys tried to
impeach me you tried to remove me from
the ballots you Unleashed covid on the
world to get rid of me like all that
stuff I'm just going to fix stuff right
we're going to fix the Middle East we're
going to get our economy going again
we're going to do things that will
Empower people to live better lives that
would be good that's the message I think
Trump should have should have been
running on this entire time instead of
the Endless Lies about the santis but
again it may all work I suppose we'll
find out in about four or five days um
here is Trump uh talking about what he's
going to do related to this disastrous
uh problem that we're having on the
southern border we have millions and
millions of people here it is not
sustainable did you see in New York City
with it getting the regular students out
and they're putting migrants in their
place we are going to have the largest
deportation effort in the history of our
country we're bringing everybody back to
where they came from we have no choice
uh can you do something about the
sanctuary cities yeah well they're going
to be ended because the Democrats are
going to end them because you can't
sustain it if you look at New York you
have a mayor of New York who Now is
really hostile to the administration
because New York City that's my place I
love New York it's gone it's had a tough
time okay we're going to have the
largest deportation in American history
his line exactly his line was we're
going to get everyone out now we know
that even before this last six months of
bananas just endless immigration into
the country illegal immigration into the
country we know that there are about 12
million illegals in the country so you
have to decide do you think that he will
actually do it and do you think that
that's the right policy to remove people
and some of the children who've been
here and and all of the issues around
that it's very easy to say I'm going to
get rid of everybody now he didn't last
time right he offered amnesty to an
awful lot of people now I get it things
have changed enough people have woken up
to what's going on at the border maybe
he'd have more juice to do it this time
but you just have to decide again to the
back drop of what we just showed you
like his obvious lies on covid like do
you think he actually would get rid of
those people do you think he would build
a wall this time blah blah blah but at
least the messaging there is truer and
certainly better than what the Democrats
are getting giving us right now because
the Democrats have given us a completely
open
border